Our next guest
is an Emmy-winning writer
who has worked on
"The Office" and "Hacks,"
created "The Good Place,"
and co-created both
"Parks and Recreation"
and "Brooklyn Nine Nine."
One day,
he's gonna break through.
he's gonna work on a show
that breaks through
with the American people.
His book, "How to Be Perfect:
The Correct Answer
to Every Moral Question,"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Michael Schur, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, my friend.
-Thank you, buddy.
How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
This is a fantastic book.
Obviously inspired by the
creation of "The Good Place."
-Right.
-At what point while you were
writing a television show
about what it means to be good
did you think, "I also want
to write a book about it"?
-Sort of toward the end.
We were in the last season.
And I really liked
reading all this stuff,
and I liked talking about it
with smart, funny people.
And at the end I was like,
you know what?
What I want to do is, like,
conduct an exit interview
for myself kind of
to see what have I learned
and how can I express it.
So I pitched the book
almost exactly two years ago
and sold it and then thought,
like, "Man, I don't know
if I have the time to do this."
And then you might remember,
there was a pandemic...
-Yeah.
-...that swept across the globe.
And so it became
my pandemic project.
I was just in my office alone
and at home, pounding away.
-You obviously have had
incredible success writing
episodic television.
I don't think there's
ever a code to crack,
but the more you do it,
the better you must get at it.
Did you find writing a book
wildly different
than working on television?
-Oh, it's so much harder.
-It's so much harder
to write a book?
-It's so much harder.
Yeah, because when you write
a TV show, you are in a room
with like 12 people
who are smart and funny,
and you pitch a joke,
and then they pitch jokes
that are better.
And you go, "Well,
let's go with your joke."
And when you're writing a book,
you write a joke,
and then you're like,
"Ah. This is all I got."
Like, I don't know.
There were a couple times
I literally e-mailed
the writing staff
of "The Good Place"
and was like, "I wrote
this joke. It sucks.
Can you make a better one?"
And they were like,
"Sure, here."
I was like, "Oh, God. I would
kill to have that room back."
-Was ethics something that
you thought about much before?
You must have thought about it
when you created
"The Good Place,"
but has it always been something
that you were interested in?
-Yeah, I was a rules dork
my whole life.
Like, when I was
in kindergarten,
if the teacher said,
"Okay, everybody, line up,"
I would line up immediately
and then I would look around
at the other kids like,
"What are you doing?
What are you doing?
She just said line up.
Did you not hear her?"
So I was always the kid
who followed every rule,
so, clearly,
it was baked in somewhere.
And then over my life, a bunch
of things have happened to me
in small and big ways
that have made me get interested
in the subject.
And then the show was obviously,
like, the culmination
of that, was really me saying,
"Okay, I'm gonna focus on this
and explicitly talk about it."
-Have you ever done something
and in the moment wrestled with,
or observed from the outside
as you were doing it,
"Oh, why -- this is --
Why am I doing this?"
-All the time. Do you not?
-Yeah, sure.
-Yeah, I feel like that --
To me, being alive on Earth
means doing things
and then immediately saying,
"Why did I do that?
What is -- Why did I do that?"
So the study of ethics is really
just getting some vocabulary
and learning some theories
about what the hell we're doing
and why we're doing it
and trying to be better.
-What about
doing the right thing
but because you want credit
for doing the right thing?
You have caught yourself
doing that?
-I have.
One of the things
that inspired the show
and then the book was that
I used to go to Starbucks
near my house
and I would get coffee.
It was like $1.73,
and I would throw the money
in the tip jar,
except I realized, one day,
I didn't just throw the money
in the tip jar.
I waited until the barista
turned around and was facing me
so that I was like,
"Yes, that's right."
You know, like, "Here.
I give you 27 cents."
And when I caught myself
doing it
and realized I had been
doing it for a long time,
it was like,
"Why do I want this credit?"
That is such a weird thing to
want, 27 cents worth of credit.
And that led me into a long,
like, rabbit hole
that I write about it the book
if you're interested in reading
what I discovered.
-It must have been weird
to write this book
during a pandemic where there
were a lot of these moral,
ethical questions, as far as how
our behavior
affects other people.
Everyone during this pandemic
was asked to make sacrifices
for the greater good.
And we have seen, obviously,
these divergent paths
that people have chosen to take.
Was it hard not to write
specifically about the pandemic?
-Yeah, it was awfully hard
not to make the whole book
about the pandemic, because
every time I'd be discussing
some kind of theory,
it would be like,
what's the right thing
to use to explain?
Oh, it's the pandemic.
It's the thing that
everyone is going through.
And there are a couple points
in the book
where I talk about that,
but things like not wanting to
wear masks and not wanting
to get vaccinated --
there's a famous problem
in philosophy
called the free-rider problem
which is basically, like,
everybody pays for a ride
on a trolley,
and you run up
and jump onto the outside
and grab hold
and get a free ride.
And it's like,
yeah, that's not cool.
Technically, everybody
got where they were going,
but everybody else did the thing
they were supposed to do
and you didn't.
And once you learn about
these problems in philosophy,
you see them everywhere.
And every time somebody started
screaming in a Jamba Juice
about how their freedom
was being trampled, I was like,
"Alright, buddy, here's this
theory, here's that theory.
Here's why
what you're doing is..."
-And most of those people
who scream in Jamba Juices
love hearing theories.
-Oh, that's
their favorite thing.
They love philosophy,
those folks.
-They love -- Yeah.
-Yeah, you can go in and you can
engage them in a philosophy
discussion pretty quickly.
Yeah.
-You did some -- First of all,
you know,
I've known you a long time.
I've never -- Again,
this is not unique to you.
A lot of people grew their
hair out during the pandemic.
-Yeah.
-And let me just say, I mean,
some people grew it out
and looked bad.
I mean, you looked fantastic.
-Thank you. Thank you. Yes.
-And it's just like --
A lot of people have, like,
a long hair style
and it only looks good one way.
-No, not in my case.
-Yeah, this is a real --
This is a twofer.
-Yeah. Now, when you said
grow your hair out,
it's more accurate to say "just
didn't get your hair cut."
-That's true.
-Like, I just didn't
get my hair cut.
-Yeah. Very well done.
-Thank you.
-You also -- You know,
an accomplished actor.
-Thank you.
-Now I'm asking
a genuine question.
Obviously, the enduring
popularity of your shows,
not just "The Good Place" which,
again, I hear all the time --
-You haven't seen it,
but you hear all the time.
-I hear all the time
that I got to watch it.
Now, is it on -- What's it on?
Where can I see it?
-It was on NBC.
-It was on this --
-It was.
It was on this network.
-I'm sorry.
-It's okay, buddy.
-I don't get NBC.
-Look -- [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
What is your audio/video setup
at home?
-What do I have?
-Yeah.
-I have Apple TV Minus.
-I see. I see.
-It's all shows that have been
cancelled by Apple.
-[ Laughs ]
You're making a good living.
I would upgrade to
at least Apple TV Neutral.
-No. No, thanks.
I just feel like TV's
gotten too liberal.
[ Laughter ]
So you are
also an accomplished actor.
-Yes.
-You played Mose
on "The Office."
-Correct.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now -- There we go.
Now, I say this because when
John Krasinski's on the show,
when Rainn Wilson
is on the show,
when BJ Novak is on the show,
when they get introduced,
the audience goes crazy,
and it's because the audience
oftentimes is watching
"The Office" now.
-Sure.
-And to a person, they always
say, "This is applause I never
got when 'The Office' aired."
-Right.
-And people are -- so are --
Do people recognize you as Mose
now more than ever?
-Ten times more than they did
at the time, yeah.
And because Mose,
if you remember,
had an unpleasant
neckbeard situation.
There it is.
-We've got a picture.
-Yeah, so...
-[ Laughter ]
The neckbeard serves
as a reverse disguise,
where when a lot of people
see me
they don't think of Mose because
they don't see that horrible...
-Yeah.
When you take a mask off
and hold it here,
do they go, "Mose"?
-I should get a mask
that has that as a print
so that when I pull it down,
it's like, "Hello."
-This looks like a guy in
a Jamba Juice who pulled down
his mask and was like, "I didn't
know this was Germany!"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, so, but now there -- I
do, I would say, get recognized
ten times more than I did
when the show was on the air.
-I bring this up because
you then did a fundraiser.
-Yes.
-And basically the conceit
of the fundraiser was the more
money you raised --
if people --
the more they donated,
the more likely you would be
to do something embarrassing.
-It started
with shaving my head.
It was like if we raised
50 grand --
This was for
the L.A. Regional Food Bank.
If we raised 50 grand,
I will shave my head.
I made that comment on Twitter
without talking to my wife
or thinking for one second
about it.
And then that happened.
And then what I realized
was the humiliation
was what people were after.
So it it became if we raise this
much, I'll do this or whatever.
I eventually changed
the shaving of the head
to regrowing the Mose beard,
wearing a Derek Jeter jersey,
because I'm a Red Sox fan,
and then people who donated
a certain amount --
including, by the way, this guy.
-Yeah.
-Could have me say
embarrassing things on camera
while I ate a hot apple pie.
Which I hate. I hate hot fruit.
So I ate a hot apple pie.
-And America.
I always forget that.
-But I love baseball. I love --
That's one out of three.
-You love baseball enough
to make up for how much
you hate apple pie.
-So I wore a Derek Jeter jersey,
grew the Mose beard,
ate hot apple pie, and said
embarrassing things on a video.
-And here's a photo of you.
Look. Just Mose doing great.
I like to think that,
in the future, Mose has done
so well that he has a nice TV.
-I like that just Mose's beard
is so gray.
That's the sense. "Oh, I guess
he made it to old age."
-We are both Red Sox fans.
We connected on that.
We have a difference --
You're a huge Patriots fan.
I'm a Pittsburgh Steelers fan.
Will you just share
with everyone what --
I made a donation to a food bank
and then I got you to say...
-I don't even remember --
I said a lot of things about --
-It was about Spygate.
-Spygate was real.
And it meant the world to me
that you finally admitted that.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Well, you're welcome.
I'm happy that money
went to a food bank.
I don't know
what you want me to say.
-Hey, buddy, thank you so much
for being here.
It's always nice
to talk with you.
Michael Schur, everybody.
"How to Be Perfect"
is available now.